hi everyone I'm a lot of HR Alonso and I
I'm going to Germany the team and Xbox
Australia are sending me and three other
totally awesome people to games come to
basically cover everything and play
unreleased games for those who don't
know by the way it's Europe's biggest
video game convention and I'm briefly
excited so I thought this was the
perfect time for me to do an Australian
accent blog which I've kind of wanted to
do for a while and if I'm talking
quietly it's because my family is asleep
and I don't want to wait to them but
first I should also mention that I have
an Xbox one to give away to celebrate
the occasion and if you'd like to win an
Xbox one the details for that are below
but for now a lesson on the Australian
accent that's someone to read out so the
words uh aunt roof route Wash oil
theater iron salmon caramel fire water
sure data ruin crayon New Orleans pecan
both again probably spitting image
Alabama lawyer coupon mayonnaise syrup
pajamas caught naturally aluminium and
envelope there are also some questions
what is it called when you throw toilet
paper on a house tp'ing house what is
the bug that when you touch it it comes
into a bowl I have absolutely no idea
what that questions referring to so I
can't answer it what does the bubbly
carbonated drink called soft drink
what do you call gym shoes runners what
do you say to address a group of people
hi I don't know what this question is
referring to either is this some other
kind of answer I'm supposed to give here
hi everyone what do you call the kind of
spider or spider-like creature that has
an oval-shaped body and extremely long
legs
a spider okay so I googled that one and
the answer that they're looking for or
the answer that Australians say is a
daddy longlegs what do you call your
grandparents I call my grandparents Nana
and pop or Grandma and Grandpa what do
you call the wheeled contraption in
which you carry groceries at the
supermarket but Rolly what do you call
it when rain falls while the sun is
shining a sun show what is the thing you
change the TV channel with remote do you
think you have an accent yes I think
everyone has an accent so that parts
done but there are totally other things
that I have to say here there are a lot
of people who comment on my videos and
try and guess what my accent is and most
the time they say British well my accent
or the way I sound is how most people
sounding majors
city's at least how all of my friends
sound how people on TV sound how most
people talk we do have a handful of
different accents not everyone sounds
the same
the Australian that seems to pop up in
American sitcoms is hilarious which i
think is why most people say that I
sound British or they don't think I'm a
straight Lane is actually that's because
they have no idea what most Australians
actually sound like speaking of which we
don't really say mate that often so
anytime that I really say mate a little
bit anyone else I know really says mate
is sarcastically though what else can I
squash here while I'm at it on my
adventuretime piano cover video some
people have said that it's weird that I
don't sing with an accent and this is
pretty common in Australia that we will
replicate the accent of whoever we're
singing another common thing that I get
which I want to say is funny but I get
it so much that it's more annoying but
still a little funny is people being
like how do you survive in Australia oh
my god they're alike sorry many things
that will kill you that and my answer to
that is that everything you know it's
massively exaggerated but of all of
those fighters that can kill you
superfast
I saw one read back once men haven't
seen any of the others I am actually
terrified of spy but I guess that's that
for this video I'm gonna go to Germany
and experience lots of lovely accents
which I'm really excited about but I'm
basically going to be talking about
everything at Gamescom on Twitter
Instagram and Facebook so all of my
social networks as always are linked
below
seriously you guys I'm going to Europe
in like three days what even is my life
what I will see you guys next week with
all of my games come stuff if you would
like to know about any games
particularly I would probably advise
tweeting at me and I'm gonna be really
good to see what you guys want to know
or what questions you might have to ask
whenever I get the chance to interview
someone so